hello here we are next to the great
waterfall of one of compact is that the
real name I have no idea for waterfalls
are tears of Jesus that has come down to
bless us all that's a fact you can look
it up in urban dictionary calm we are
doing something that is once again not
within my comfort zone hiking
cardiovascular activity blood of brushes
to the penis to the legs
save me well we're gonna go hiking David
and scared her enough because he's
afraid of fight you guys are just
[ __ ] me over huh we went rock
climbing yesterday and our good look
I'll have you both my hands God
hiking seems to be like the popular
thing to do nowadays like every time I
look at somebody's Instagram they're
hiking somewhere hashtag living life
hash tag nature hash tag active Fitness
you [ __ ] done edges but because of
that Mariel is always on my ass about
hiking thank you for that by the way you
[ __ ] hipster [ __ ] come over here
we know each other for years
you gonna trick me and [ __ ] take me over
here and do this outtie commercial I
have in the chantry flats before but the
big difference between now and then is
that I drove this time and you [ __ ]
know that I'm scared of [ __ ] Heights
and when you go up the chantry flats you
just look at the looming death over a
cliff so I drove very slow I'm that dude
when you drive up a mountain that
everybody passes by like get the [ __ ]
out the way fat-ass
thank you for letting me hold more stuff
than I actually should put that around
there you go right there
double backpack look like a jackass
there you go
yeah but I've been going on hikes a lot
more since last year specifically
because I I hurt myself so working out
with like a lot of heavy weights was out
of the question I've ever needed disc in
my back you know just some of the basic
stuff but we're over here at Chantry
flats where Vince this son of a [ __ ]
didn't tell me that we were going to and
I have a great fear of heights and we
were traveling up this mountainside
we're instantly one breeze could have
just tossed our car off and we could
have all been dead but that's cool
though yeah but we're here to do a hike
your name oh oh yeah you're cute dude if
you ran somebody they'd be dead in a
second that's cute this is what I'm
talking about people don't know this but
we live in LA I'm over here pentagram or
go what is he a ramp a ramp maybe look
at the it's a friendly I want one now a
dog the little ones I like hella key
they like jumping on yeah you seen those
idiot look at that love attention
he was like putting his hair over you
like nah nah nah don't cut me here penny
here yeah yeah I know [ __ ] yeah of a
majority of the hike is relatively flat
it's not that crazy mountainous very
terrain e type of [ __ ] the the first
quarter of it is actually paved so you
go downwards which is fantastic that's
my skill I can roll down a house super
fast but did you know what that means
that when you come back you gotta walk
right back up that [ __ ] watch how you
got our food watch out you got our food
what about watch out don't hurt yourself
sweetie my eyes what is going on she
just poked him in the eye with the river
hat
so this time when we went to Chantry
class it was a lot better the last time
I went it was like a hundred degrees or
so today it was very gloomy I think that
kind of kept people away so there
weren't that many people on the trail so
it made it a little more personable
which I enjoyed did not put on the
sunscreen to save my fare Geisha skin so
we're here we're going to give you a
basic example of a little survival
tactic you see this water if it's still
you can drink it if the water is
completely still you drink the water
bacteria won't kill you [ __ ] look at
it it's water I've never seen water
before say this the water is flowing
it's bad for you
well if you guys know the California
isn't a huge drought so it rained not
too long ago so the last time I went the
waterfall was very shitty but this time
it was just gushing like a large man who
holding his piss for a few days just
hello everybody my name is fat free duck
best tour guide in the whole of the
United States of America remember leaves
of three let it touch it you should
touch it all the time advice number two
if the ground is soft make sure you put
a lot of weight on it first to test to
see if it's good if you fall that is
just a product of the environment look
at my home
I built it with my own two feet
I am a nature expert it's actually what
I majored in in college nature expert
isn't every now and then I like to speak
to earth get the [ __ ] off me okay gotcha
so here we have out here in the wild we
have ourselves a corny-ass korean go out
in the distance pretending to meditate
let's take a look
yeah she's a wild little brother a shake
cuz you never know when well run out of
time
what you gonna do okay welcome god I'm
good right it's kind of interesting
Muriel has this squat challenge thing
that she's been doing and then Lynn and
Muriel decided to do the squat challenge
thing together so they stopped at a
certain point they were squatting their
asses off which was kind of cool like I
appreciate this I mean a hike is already
a workout and then you want to work out
on top of workout hey that's [ __ ]
dumb here we have a bunch of degenerate
Asians they're doing squats
of course because the hike isn't tiring
enough as it is they got to make sure
they get their extra workout in we have
the riff BAM
then we have a corner and a kiss like a
sheep second mother popper oh hey they
wanted to do those squats during the
hike
turns out the legs were useless later
couldn't use him upper body was
perfectly fine have you seen that dog on
Family Guy where their legs are just
dead in the back it just drags his body
Lynden Muriel great job girls
did it did it did right under it you're
so short fetal in here hmm oh god I
can't do it my back
so by the time we got to the waterfall
we were obviously very very hungry and
then we brought out that delicious
actually mean that we got from Yama's so
I'm gonna be recording on this uh iPhone
because we got this loud ass annoying
waterfall you know in nature right now
that we're here we have the great scenic
area behind us we had this beautiful
waterfall we got this vendôme EES girl
next to the hahaha and it just makes it
into a perfect place to have a great
picnic and what better thing to have
then raw fish and sushi and tomorrow
it's going to be great it's gonna be
great people a lot of the times when you
guys go to Japanese restaurants you guys
see this green leaf get it and you think
this is a garnish this is not a garnish
it's an edible garnish actually it's a
shiso leaf I Korean you call it kidney
and Vietnamese you call it a feet oh it
doesn't
Ralphie so well what wrap people Seto
yeah yeah so it's really good it's kind
of well how would you describe it like
pepper it is a minty very Irby basil ii
very floral but i like to take the shiso
leaf and then wrap it in the sashimi and
it adds that nice little vegetative
floral Irby little crunch to whatever
you're eating so don't throw this away
it's not just the garnish eat it with
your with your sashimi I like the hike
this time because like I said before
there weren't that many people so we
caught to be in our own little area
there was like this place next to the
waterfall that had a kind of had flat
rocks we ate our sashimi
we had our California rolls digged into
it and it was nice
we got a resident Japanese bastard
Japanese acequia negative-3 bastard a
numbered negative 10 K sake [ __ ]
got about a unit this has fashioned a
shiso and
salmon and a ginger coach delish delish
totes delish bro yeah
what are you having that breath it's
called like a California roll oh my god
it's so like with that like awesome
sauce oh my god you know what first when
I saw like these real small eyed people
even out like what are the e oh what are
they getting like what is that green
stuff how is all the colors yeah what do
you think Janine
I don't like God because I just roll
right now generally when you go hiking
or if you go to any nature place where
there's like a pooled form of water you
will see mosquitoes I am one of those
things that mosquitoes love a lot of
love a lot of cushion for the pushin as
they say I think that's a sexual
reference I don't think that's what I
meant at all but they love me
TLC warned you not to take waterfall o
go chasing waterfalls
your way or nothing at all you're moving
too fast holy [ __ ] Barrett Barrett walk
okay man they call me Tookie
Pookie the bear Willie I represent the
hibernation hibernation cut all day
y'all just wait to that winner comes up
I'll be like this I think that one of
the things that people forget is that
the same route that you came in the same
route that you got back up so this route
starts at a decline which means that all
the way back up for the rest of this
mile it's a constant 45-degree angle now
mind you if you're fat such as I be
prepared your calves will hurt your
breasts will jiggle and sometimes you
just might contemplate killing yourself
so for me I'm when I do a hike I'm
always looking for shortcuts that's what
I'm looking for and so I saw this path
that kind of cut the road up so you
don't have to go all the way around I
was like you know what I'm gonna take
this turned out it's not a shortcut it's
the exact same amount of time just a lot
more difficult kind of [ __ ] is that
instead of taking the normal route David
decided to rock climb he's now a
professional had only saved us five
seconds it wasn't worth it
survival guy oh my god
they're gonna regret this in 3 2 1
did you regret that it was so cool when
they were paving this walkway literally
Bambi came in was like nah [ __ ] that
[ __ ] tah tah tah Bambi you rude [ __ ]
it's interesting because in LA you guys
I think people who don't live here the
only thing that you guys think about is
like a very busy city where you know
it's a great nightlife and stuff but the
great thing about LA - once again I said
there are a lot of things that you don't
know about like there there's a lot of
great hiking spots near here you
wouldn't think that Chantry flats was
actually anywhere near LA but it is and
and that's what I enjoyed about its kind
of like an escape that's very close that
you don't have to go too far for so if
you guys have never been to Chantry
flats or any of the other hiking spots
in LA should I give it a go hiking is
very fun for people who enjoy not me per
se no I I did enjoy those like them I
don't like really fiend for hiking but
it's great to be away from your [ __ ] you
know what I mean I know that we bought a
camera [ __ ] like that but it's kind of
nice not to be checking your phone every
every like hour being next to tree the
Mexican nature I think that's just as
humans we need that we need to kind of
unwind and separate ourselves and unplug
us from that city life and I like doing
that by going out on these like forest
even adventures and it's great to deal
with friends and family kind of proud of
myself this was actually a lot easier
than I than it was before when I did it
last time because I've been consistently
in the gym and working out I kind of
proud of myself you know I'm saying you
know David so pat yourself on the back
yeah get out there and explore people or
at least do it with me I'm kinda I kind
of watch you guys to to go out and do it
too and I don't want to keep on telling
people like hey go out there and explore
your life I'm not doing it myself and I
think one of the things that I realized
was that you know when I tell these
stories that mostly stories was when I
was like you know in my early 20s and
when I was a teenager and I try to
recollect stories from now and I don't
have any because I'm too busy trying to
work and keep my head down in like
paperwork and trying to build a business
here and there that I forget to live
life and you know we got one life to
live
so I will make sure that I really just
take advantage of that and I hope you
guys two men who see y'all next time
Mariel gives me crap sharing I don't I
don't go outside enough look at me now
next to goats and flies I'm I'm the Oh
God
I'm all here living out loud [ __ ]